ich springe heute mit meiner Virtual
Reality Brille vom höchsten Punkt in
Minecraft und schaue ob ich kotzen muss
bevor wir dieses experimenterdings
durchführen haben wir noch einige andere
Dinge zu tun denn zuererst danke schön
für diesen Komar ihr seht schon ich kann
jetzt springen ohne dass ich so machen
das ist kein autoump aber ich habe es
jetzt einfach auf eine Taste gelegt
Kommentar Nummer der mir geschrieben
wurde war das hier luca du kannst auch
mit deiner steinspitzhacke Lapis lzuli
abhauen ist mir aber scheißegal Lapis
lzuli ist ein korrupter Diamant der W
ger ein Diamant ich sit aber nicht sehen
sich sogar verfickt komplett ähnlich ich
sage nein
zul nächste Sache Freunde wir packen uns
mal eben fix das Bett ein denn wir gehen
ins Boot und fahren rüber Bo diger Alter
mir wird direkt schwindelig wenn ich ins
Boot
Steig moin ich Wasser ersten Augenblick
verlassen wir unsere Insel und fahren
nicht zu dem Festland sondern nach hier
oh mein
[Musik]
Gott oh mein Gott
diger was ist das denn guck und da ist
ein Piratenschiff dann habe ich es doch
richtig gesehen in Folge 1 oh mein Gott
checkt ihr wie nah das von unserer Insel
ist diger ich drück nichts ne das
reagiert halt wirklich darauf ob ich das
bewege deswegen wird mir auch die ganze
Zeit so schlecht wenn ich Boot fahre da
vorne ist unsere spawninsel da ist das
festern auf dem wir schon waren und hier
ist dieser fette
Berg und Piratenschiff und da fahren wir
jetzt
erstmal so kotzübel eine Stunde später
so Freunde wir sind
angekommen auf dem
Piratenschiff wir haben wir haben eine
Kiste da vorne um die Ecke
dementsprechend schauen wir da mal
direkt
rein wow das ist sogar echt ganz
okay nehmen wir direkt mit und meistens
ist doch hier in dem Bereich da unten
auch noch eine Kiste oder guck mal der
Profi eine
Schatzkarte wir finden heute ein Schatz
also wir suchen ihn zumindest ob wir ih
finden weiß noch nicht so ganz ich setze
mein Bett jetzt einfach mal hier vorne
hin und wir gehen eine Runde schlafen so
dass wir dann tatsächlich auch schon den
nächsten
Tag Leute Trix
hier
ich hasse diese Dinger wir haben den
nächsten Tag im Projekt Minecraft we oh
mein
Gott ey wie geil sieht das hier aus Mo
Leute Trix hier ach und
jetzt ich könnte do echt wieder kotzen
wir schauen uns jetzt allerdings mal
unsere Schatzkarte oh mein
Gott wie geil diger ich halte dir
wirklich so in der
Hand ich kann es nur immer wieder sagen
aber diese Videos auf Youtube haben
überhaupt nicht den Weib den ich hier
gerade in echt spüre diger ich kann mich
einfach hier
hinsetzen und es fühlt sich
an als wäre ich gerade wirklich in
Minecraft außer dass ich jetzt halt
natürlich nass werde wir steigen zurück
ins Bötchen und fahren erstmal aufs
Festland da vorne weil das wollte ich
mir e noch mal anschauen das sieht
nämlich auf jeden Fall sehr sehrer
dieses Boot ne das fäht wie Sandra in
Fahrschule gebt euch mal wie krass das
aussieht
ich glaube halt wirklich dass es auf
YouTube nicht so wirklich rüberkmt aber
für mich hier
gerade irre und was haben wir bitte für
ein Schildkröten aufkommen egal schauen
wir uns die Schatzkarte an oh mein Gott
der Schatz direkt
hier ich sag's euch Leute Countdown ab
jetzt das wird das schnellste wie ich
jemals ein Schatz in Minecraft gefunden
habe ich bin ja meistens nicht so gut
drin und brauch mal ziemlich lang aber
ich sag's euch jetzt wird
rasiert das wird das schnellste wie ich
jemals ein Schatz gefunden
[Musik]
habe oh mein
Gott
unterwasseratmung egal Freunde sagen wir
nicht nein nehmen wir natürlich alles
mit Ey dieses autojump Ding bzw dass ich
jetzt auf eine Taste das nimmt mir so
viel Arbeit ab wir haben die Schatzkarte
gefunden dementsprechend kann ich das ja
rausschmeißen ist ja jetzt keine
Umweltverschmutzung oder ist ja Papier
ja genauso wie wenn man Taschentuch im
Wald schmeiß das ist ja eigentlich
mee FS gut bei
dir guck mal der macht
nichts das habe ich ja noch nie erlebt
dass ein Zombie freundlich ist tschüss
ig wünsche noch einen schönen Tag ich
muss nämlich noch mal eben kurz ein
bisschen Gras abbauen denn ich habe auf
meiner Farm ein bisschen zu wenig
Weizenkörner meine Farm soll auf jeden
Fall noch ein bisschen größer werden
deswegen baue ich hier vorne jetzt
einfach noch mal ein bisschen Gras ab
nehmen wir einfach mit Leute die Musik
die gerade im Hintergrund läuft ist
übrigens die von Nintendos ich habe die
letztens bei tiktok gesehen und fand die
eigentlich passend hier fürs Minecraft
Projekt weil die halt auch so ein
entspannten Weib hat ne guck mal das
sieht ja auch alles irgendwie ziemlich
nice finde ich also klar ich mag un
Insel weil wir haben da auch unsere Ruhe
aber hier ist ja auch cool kann man
bestimmt auch irgendwie coole Abenteuer
erleben coole Höhlen bin ich auch schon
gespannt auf die erste höhlenerfahrung
schaut mal
oh schon interessant
hier wow komm wir nehmen uns ein
bisschen Lava mit sagt man doch nicht
nein
[Musik]
oder danke oh
CL crazy guck mal wer da ist es sieht
von der Statik aber nicht so machbar aus
so oder so meine lieben Freunde würde
ich sagen lassen wir den ganzen Wald und
die ganze coole Insel hier vorne jetzt
allerdings mal hinter uns und bewegen
uns zurück in unser Bötchen und
dementsprechend zurück nach Hause denn
ich habe fünf weizenkören das jetzt
nicht so viel geworden aber auf jeden
Fall ein bisschen was um die Farm zu
erweitern
Igor wir fahren zurück nach Hause machen
zu vor allerdings noch einen kleinen
Stopp hier eben an Land denn ich wollte
ein bisschen Sand mitnehmen um mich
gleich auf meiner Insel bisschen
hochzubauen ihr seht ja bereits im Titel
eingeblendet ich springe heute vom
höchsten Punkt in Minecraft sind
irgendwie 250 Blöcke oder so und werde
schauen wie sich das mit dieser VR
Brille anfühlt und ob ich mich halt
übergeben muss und während wir hier am
Piratenschiff vorbeifahren zurück zu
unserer Insel oh mein Gott
diger ich glaube so fühlen sich wirklich
schiffsbrüchiger also obvious fühlen die
sich nicht so weil die haben ein
bisschen härteres Leben als ich mit ein
vrbrille in meiner schönen Wohnung in
Köln in Minecraft
aber schon echt gruselig apropos
gruselig allerdings meine dam diger ich
drüc nichts ich will einfach nur gerade
ausfahren ich habe euch im letzten Part
Minecraft war ja gefragt was eure
kuriosesten crafting Rezepte sind bzw
die die ihr einfach komplett dumm findet
und haben ganz viele das hier
reingeschrieben ein Kürbiskuchen weil
man für ein Kürbiskuchen die mehr
braucht als ein Kürbis Zucker und Milch
oder was das da ist dann haben auch noch
voll viele die Uhr reingeschickt wo ich
allerdings direkt sagen muss die Uhr
fand ich jetzt gar nicht mal so schlimm
also ich meine das Gold und ein bisschen
Redstone mit drin ist ich meine was
sollen die noch machen die können jetzt
ja nicht ein komplettes Schweizer
Uhrwerk irgendwie nachcraften und was
auch viele meinten war ey Luca wenn man
Honig in crafting table packt kriegt man
einfach drei Zucker raus ist auch ein
bisschen kupt na ja okay also wir haben
auf jeden Fall fünf Weizenkörner das
heißt zack zack zack zack zack und wir
können die Weizenkörner BAM Bam Bam Bam
Bam anpflanzen vorne schaut
mal wir haben wzen im entsprechend
können wir die drei neuen Körner auch
anpflanzen Wahnsinn guck mal dann geizen
wir auch nicht rum machen wir hier vorne
noch eine Fackel hin haben die ein
bisschen mehr Licht es gibt in unserer
Welt aber generell gerade gar kein Licht
mehr deswegen würde ich sagen ich glaub
ich habe gerade zum ersten Mal den Jump
da
geschafft danke ich würde sagen wir
platzieren unser Bett wieder schön ne in
der Fackel gehen noch einmal kurz
schlafen sodass wir jetzt wenn die Sonne
wieder aufgegangen ist und wir den
nächsten Tag in Minecraft wire geschafft
haben wir uns jetzt mit unserer neuen
Tastenkombination dem dauerhüpfen
hochbauen können auf eine Höhe von
insgesamt 81 Blöcken meine Damen und
herreno von der 81 Block hohen Höhe
meine Damen und Herren werde ich heute
das soziale experimentwagen und
runterpringen mit
einer ich bin so hoch dass ich
Grafikfehler habe hier am Himmel e for
real wenn ich mich hier
hinsetze ey das ist kein
Spaß ich krieg brutale Höhenangst hier
oben aber gut Freunde ich auch ans Ende
der Welt für euch für Content von daher
machen wir den Sprung und springen mit
der Virtu reality Brille von der höchste
Minecraft oh mein
Gott oh mein
Gott alter
Schwede oh wow
diger das war
[Musik]
heftig und es ging schnell ich lass mal
einen sandblock hier für uns zum
Verständnis dass wir immer wieder uns
dran erinnern von hier habe ich ein
soziales Experiment gestartet komm wir
setzen sogar noch eine Fackel drauf
super was ist das da jetzt für ein
Grafikfehler ach der speichert das immer
ne guck mal wenn ich jetzt hier ein
Block anfange
abzubauen das ist voll geil wenn man
auch Obsidian irgendwann dann abbaut in
der Höhle das dauert aber noch ein
bisschen obwohl sollen wir in der
nächsten Folge in Höhle gehen können wir
eigentlich mal machen schreibt in die
Kommentare wir sehen uns übermorgen
wieder um 20 Uhr beim nächsten Teil
Minecraft war ja